ma per arrivare ci siamo nascosti
per tenerla fuori perché i mari quando
vale il padre quando insomma
le faccio sorprende
sentiamo quello pugliese
ma io così chiunque diverso dal solito
vi spiego se una mia fan che compie gli
anni oggi e mi hanno chiesto di fare una
sorpresa quindi tra poco battere
passiamo a sorpresa che non sa che io
sto andando da lei quindi le farà una
sorpresa gli auguri e la marcerò quale
compiuto delle facoltà e ho preso
qualcosina quindi vi porterò con me
vedremo sieve la sua reazione è ciò che
vedrete state sto preparando in pratica
le ho preso una bustina con un unicorno
proprio assalto in corso ma per tutti
tranne la mia sorellina consolidati
vabbè comunque questo bustine
supercafoni corno lionello adesso conta
chiami di kozuch è corredato in quanto è
carino
[Musica]
per non lasciare il bianco quindi le
metto questo come in questione macarons
rosa dell'asia un lipgloss ma va bene
devo dare anche solo come pecore che
siamo in una stanza poi questo paesino e
vibrante d onore conoscerlo
ora vanno da dietro bassi
poi qua o una card scrivere qualcosa e
non sono un po g
e poi un messaggio di farle uno slam
così a qualcosa di fatto da me è in
realtà volevo fargli uno stanco la con
la trasparente sto aspettando che arrivi
doveva arrivare all'ultima nei
consiglieri tanto va bene quindi in
realtà non si muova del fauno secolo con
la mia che fine facciamo assieme
resterete mai fare un blend dei cake
slime infatti già messo la colla bianca
poi metti un profumo da parte nostra né
tutti e va bene possibile
poi mette un po di gel da barba che si
senta bello sposo e sarà un bel po di
suoni mr spero che sono destinati di sly
ma se mi segue sa pezzo di sì
comunque tra l'altro lei ha anche una
fan page su instagram si chiama gli
occhi di anita stories quindi andate a
seguirla su instagram
allora vi racconto tutto proprio che una
cosa prima che mi arrivino 10.000 e mail
in cui mi chiedete di venire un altro
compleanno
allora questa è stata una coincidenza
perché lei vive vicino a me è stata una
coincidenza anche perché io l'ho
incontrato e vi racconto brevemente la
storia in pratica era un centro
commerciale che c'è qua vicino al centro
più o meno e stanno provando dei vestiti
da ellen barry era dopo le belle con
vitale stiamo provando dei vestiti
allora aggiungo del bagnoschiuma guarda
che bello poi con il corno questo lo
aggiungo si è passato perché con un bel
profumo al lime stava formando dei
vertici esprit vita grama ho messo una
foto con un vestito di pull and bear
quindi ho messo una foto in camerino
non si vedeva niente ci vedeva solamente
il camerino e io con il vestito giusto
l'ho messo a punto gli ho chiesto mi
piace questo vestito e abbiamo messo il
font altro insomma poi tipo quanto
sempre passato dieci minuti quindici
minuti dopo sono andata da primark
perché sempre nello stesso centro
commerciale
stavo guardando delle magliette mi sono
inchinato per vedere delle magliette
altri settori
tutto questo bimba carinissimo assieme
sono spaventato ovviamente perché
spuntata lavorerà improvviso da niente e
noi molto più bello monica come stai
come ti chiami stiamo bracciate avevo
fatto un tempio per carinaro dolcissima
e nel frattempo vitale fare un parallelo
con il padre di questa bimba è evitare
gli altri cosa che gli ho detto tipo
altro pochino anche perché strana
coincidenza che ci siamo incontrate così
in pratica il padre ha detto che lei
stava guardando inter che a me come ho
visto la mia foto che ero dopo
ha subito capito che quel centro
commerciale
va detto che ha svegliato il padre che
stava dormendo per accompagnarla subito
di corso al centro commerciale cioè il
padre un santo veramente ringraziamo il
basket è veramente un falso e sono
arrivati in tempo stranamente riuscita
incontrarmi praticamente subito perché
centro commerciale molto grande
tra l'altro fanno pestandoli andata chen
espiantare pia solo che ho detto
stiamo da primark un momento perché
sapete che io adoro primark tutti fermi
cercate sono sempre lì e quindi è stata
una coincidenza ma l'era carini stimare
a tante guzzonato tornata su tenera
medico è una coincidenza e lenin e va
quindi non vi offendete scott e sono già
rivolte delle richieste di venire a
trovarvi o al vostro compleanno e lo
sapete che non sono in italia quindi non
è proprio possibile per me non è un po
di colorate rosa quindi questa è stata
una coincidenza tra l'altro la
organizzato il fratello quindi santo
anche il castello
sono tutti benissimo strada e siete tipo
degli agenti segreti e io vado i nostri
presidi in italia vedrete stupito dalle
mie storie riconoscerete subito dove
solo è successo in puglia anche era
successo quando sono stata in vacanza in
cui la sinistra
sapete è meglio dei miei spostamenti
sono stata in salento e pubblicato le
storie e poco dopo mi arrivavano i
messaggi in direct io sono il mondo o
magari ero lì prima persona che dice
moretti ho vista ma non so perché ma
ancora siamo in finale
non vi preoccupate un accordo come ho
già detto su instagram ma non vi
preoccupate davvero sono contenta di
sfruttarli infatti anche affrontato
quindi ragazze
marina la ragazza era bimba di lecce che
la supercar in a poi una ragazza più
grande di ostuni su quelle super carina
davvero impazienti essere tutte terry
per salutarvi allora eccola queste metto
questito rocchi con questi sono sì
arancioni e gialli solo dei colori e poi
ovviamente mettiamo le palline dei cake
non so nemmeno se ci sarà dopo in questo
contenitore questa di lost o prendere un
contenitore più grande perché si deve
accettare le proposte va bene con un
pochino
allora ragazzi quasi pronto e ancora un
pochino ricordo o un bel po di spazio
come tributo di spalline che vuole
conoscerlo un po neutro come ok
aboliscono i pochi eccolo qua
[Musica]
[Applauso]
in più è anche profumato
vediamo se ci metto di glitter
spero che le piace al rosa davvero you
to tema rosa perché mi piace rosa e
perché è una bimba
però se le piace rosa comunque un po di
critter rosa e poi questo mini
frappuccino guardate tutto carino ma
troppo tenero questo lo mettiamo al
centro poi ovviamente se vuole lo potra
togliere la nostra elmo giocando della
scura no no poi dopo è impossibile
recuperare beh no ho soffiato sui
criteri mi son caduti addosso
addio
secondo piatto febbre interpretò glieli
[Musica]
guardatelo cadendo con assist e
finissimo tempo b lettera si rendano
ancora no
ok ragazzi ho tolto i glitter almeno
spero tutti quindi ecco qua lo slime
vado a chiuderlo e aggiungo anche due
pezzettini di glitter questi verbi di
quel colore preferito e questi rosa o
per cambiare un po how dimenticato di
fare una cosa che ho fatto è pratico una
cosa che faccio da sempre membri tra
sempre tantissimi anni quando regalo un
peluche o pupazzi sempre un po del mio
profumo sopra così ti rimane addosso il
mio profumo io ho io uso o io adoro il
profitto il cis mi il victory stick di
victoria's secret coccola spesso anche
praticata di vaniglia e cocco infatti
subita liste perché un profumo di torta
comunque
un pochettino spero che vi sarà utile
anche voi questo consiglio perché poi è
ancora che bello però un regalo che
profuma anche e infatti ho notato non
aveva sempre fatto però anche da
victoria's secret
non è una pista per i disonesti che
comunque contati in mano il pacchettino
con la busta che mettono anche la carta
sopra la spruzzo ancora profumo di
vittoria sigle è stato uguale allora non
sono l'unica che lo fa è comunque eccoci
qua siamo pronti
mi pare ci siamo nascosti
melo fuori perché sta arrivando fare il
padre
sorprese ci pentiamo quello
però conoscendo quanto siete svegli
[Applauso]
quando da un problema mio
eccola
la notte
[Applauso]
[Musica]
magari
[Applauso]
grazie
[Musica]
questa cosa
[Applauso]
ancora no fra poco meno di un mese 33
[Musica]
ora praticamente
[Applauso]
ho fatto un blog da fare
si ok allora io sofia e con gli 11 anni
e alle donne che scuola vuoi fare
totti
è bello che fratello fatto l'artista
piace insegnare
bravo bravo ma voi quando prima è quella
brutta non ti dico di approvarle
ecco perché
però allora ho fatto anche uno slide e
se volevo chiedere maggiori emittenti ok
perché ho pensato non solo
ora egli è piazzata lì slime un no
perché non avete nessun posto a riguardo
pianificate
di fatto uno style
speriamo allora se si indurisce e
country
il buio
insomma
e ora
si potrebbe poi bravissimo troppo male
estreme
tutti gli effetti
che fare
niente normalmente
sempre
e poi ho provato a fare
[Musica]
bene bene alla spiaggia
e a me per vero che stavo aspettando la
cosa per me
mi è arrivato
però volta non avremo
era d'accordo
e poi stavo dicendo prima della bomba di
latina
male
ok quindi andate a seguire
ma mi raccomando bene
e poi continua
anche
[Applauso]
il cavallo canale youtube
allora lei si chiama daf il vero
perdonatemi mi occupo di
al pubblico io porto l'ignoranza
[Musica]
insomma migliorato e continuerò mai e
dalla di piante segno la forza e la
sorellina perché non
la domenica qualche fly
[Musica]
sembra lì così lo possiamo vedere anche
la riprendiamo il mondo che lo sta bene
ma testino il mio canale
bottino fm quinte
e poi sono nato con la bacchetta nelle
mani non lavate e 167 io ti rispondo
e lì
e alla camera
io ero io
[Applauso]
e per tutto
minsk ha rischiato
con venti minuti
devi resistere alla vetta
nato
il mascarpone e cioccolato
[Applauso]
bene
grazie amici
[Applauso]
ma che vi fosse
della schiuma da barba
[Applauso]
ragazzi allora come avete visto abbiamo
incontrato spero che si senta l'odio
perché
eravamo
alla stazione c'è un po di gente quindi
spero che si sentono ovvio perché non po
incasinato perché zampa anche po fuori
allora stavo dicendo mi ero dimenticato
di quanto è difficile fare blog per
strada con tutto quel casino delle
marche comunque io non ci posso credere
di come non so neanche come esprimerlo a
parole ma il fatto che solo la mia
presenza porti felicità a una persona mi
emoziona tantissimo è veramente sono
troppo felice di questo mi vien in
inglese in inglese great book 36
siamo tornati a casa siamo passati a
fare un po di spesa abbiamo trovato un
sacco di cose vegetariano interessanti e
poi vogliamo provarle 5 vitale sta
impostando la pizza del stasera pizza
perché abbiamo il forno nuovo e volevo
dire un paio di sempre di cose primo
saluta più volte l'incontro sono
felicissima anche quando qui incontrato
in italia un tempo pagando sono state in
sardegna quando vi incontro sono
felicissimo quindi assolutamente fermata
emesse vive del 3 per strada
scusate vicini fanno cantina o veramente
veramente felice di potervi rendere
impedisce anche solo con la mia presenza
davvero incredibile che vogliate
sto bene e spero di incontrarvi tutti
abbracciarvi tutti più questo gusti b e
ora vi salutiamo lasciato in me like su
questo blog se volete vederne altri
ciao ciao
[Musica]